depuis le 7 janvier la chine d'abord est
désormais le reste du monde connaît une
épidémie extrêmement virulente du
coronavirus la situation est
préoccupante et exige de la part de tous
une coopération responsable le temps de
l'incubation du virus étant de 14 jours
et les patients sains difficilement
détectables comme tchernobyl le virus
risque de ne pas s'arrêter à nos
frontières il est essentiel que les
pouvoirs publics puissent garantir à nos
concitoyens que nous sommes prêts à
affronter l'épidémie
monsieur le premier ministre le pire
n'est jamais certain mais nous avons le
devoir de nous préparer au pire et en la
matière un principe de précaution
s'impose
monsieur le premier ministre et les
français doivent mesurer toutes les
conséquences de l'utilisation de ce 49 3
le 49-3 seul passage en force sans vote
le 49 3 c'est un texte qui sera adopté
et qui n'est pas financé le 49-3 c'est
aussi le fait tout simplement que des
centaines de questions sur les
agriculteurs sur la pénibilité sur les
carrières longues et autres resteront
sans réponse il existe une alternative
cet achat la chine c'est notre
proposition de résolution qui vous fait
une profession très clair mettez un
nouveau texte sur la table
financé complet en temps législatif
programmé et qui évitera toute
obstruction parlementaire parce que les
français en ont assez
entre d'un côté les insoumis qui veulent
bloquer de l'autre les indignés de la
majorité qui refuse le débat de fond et
ils vous envoient donc doses à dos et il
regrette ce spectacle désolant d'une
guérilla parlementaire qui est devenu
irresponsables qui est devenu
inconséquente et qui tout simplement est
devenue incompréhensible
eh bien nous les républicains on a fait
le choix du débat sérieux et responsable
alors monsieur le promu nice revenez à
la raison
respecter le parlement
et refuser le 49-3 la france restera
telle la france sans ses agriculteurs
monsieur le premier ministre nous
connaissons tous la réponse à cette
question alors battez vous pour eux pour
nous et quand allez vous entendre
enfin nos propositions pour le monde
agricole votre gouvernement vient de
fermer la centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim et vous aurez ainsi tenu la
promesse de françois hollande fait aux
plus radicaux des écologistes cette
armature est un gâchis écologique
économique et humain dois je vous
rappeler que l'électricité d'origine
nucléaire est en moyenne 80 fois moins
productrice de ce2 co2 que celle du
charbon est 40 fois moins que celle du
gaz ainsi la fermeture de fessenheim va
se traduire par l'émission de 10
millions de tonnes de co2
supplémentaires par an le nucléaire
français présente un avantage compétitif
sur le plan économique et sur le plan
environnemental
c'est le giec qui le dit pensez vous que
la situation de notre pays et de nos
concitoyens soient si florissante que
l'on puisse priver la france de ses
avantages
[Musique]